la carte et la castonguette du nom de
Claude castonguet le père de l'Assurance
Maladie donne au Québécois un accès
gratuit aux soins de santé à la fin des
années 60 plus besoin de payer la
consultation du médecin comme les tests
en laboratoire et l'imagerie sont
couverts à l'hôpital un grand nombre de
patients vont directement aux urgences
c'est un peu l'avènement de la médecine
de corridor à 9h30 mon garçon il en
pouvait plus on est obligé de revenir il
y a pas pensé Robert Bourassa a visité
cette salle d'urgence de la Cité de la
santé à Laval il y a vu 57 patients dans
les corridors mais il y a des
engagements qui ne sont pas négociables
c'est d'avoir une médecine civilisée au
Québec le détournement d'ambulance
engorgement et file d'attente politique
d'admission inefficace et mauvaise
répartition de lit ce sont là des
problèmes vécus depuis 10 ans dans les
salles d'urgence à Montréal et à Québec
on cherche toujours pour le remède à
l'engorgement une décennie plus tard le
gouvernement va développer des hôpitaux
de jour et des unités de gériatrie
je pense qu'il faut quand même laisser
aux mesures le temps de se mettre en
place mais les images des couloirs
encombrées de civières continuent de
faire les manchettes en 1990 le ministre
de la Santé veut y mettre fin allez j'ai
la place publique avec vos urgences vous
allez faire peur aux administrateurs
puis à partir de ça ils vont vous donner
de l'argent fini marquis vaccotter
répond avec son le Groupe tactique
d'intervention ce groupe de médecins est
vite rebaptisé la police des urgences et
a pour mandat d'insuffler de
l'efficacité dans le système pour qu'on
ait des solutions qui vont faire en
sorte qu'on reconnaisse la lourdeur des
clientèles que la rémunération du
personnel la situation s'améliore un peu
mais l'attente dépasse encore trop
souvent les 48 heures pour ceux qui ont
besoin d'être hospitalisés la pression
est forte sur le personnel soignant mais
s'il y a plus de place en haut sur les
étages de 48 heures dans le corridor ce
qui doit se traduire par le trottoir
depuis l'hiver dernier ça n'arrête pas
l'urgence accueille deux fois plus de
patients que sa capacité des personnes
âgées surtout le ministre Pauline Marois
voudrait bien régler de façon permanente
les débordements dans les urgences son
plan réussira-t-il les gouvernements
changent les promesses restent le chef
Notre-Dame parce que extrêmement
problématique ou tournant des années
2010 le problème persiste jamais encore
53 heures d'attente non ce que je veux
c'est un rayon X pour mon pied va
essayer
plus de malades chroniques à domicile
les urgences continuent de déborder
une patiente meurt sur une civière de
l'Hôpital Maisonneuve-Rosemont après
quatre jours d'attente en fin de semaine
on va trouver ça en place pour les
patients datant d'hébergement depuis
2008 la ligne 81 a pour mission de
limiter les visites inutiles à l'urgence
en 2014 l'ancien président de la
Fédération des médecins spécialistes
arrivent avec ses solutions si on veut
baisser cette attente là l'urgence il
faut se faire sortir les patients qui
prennent des lits qui ne devraient pas
le Premier ministre le goal vie aussi
était ministre de la Santé en 2002 sous
un gouvernement pékiste il instaure
bulletin des urgences nous sommes toutes
et tous un peu prisonnier de ce préjugé
tenace qui veut que toutes les urgences
du Québec soient problématiques après 50
ans et une pandémie la situation dans
les urgences a pris des proportions de
crise provoquant l'implantation de la
cellule de crise du ministre du B
ici Anne-Louise despaty Radio-Canada
Montréal